hello
and welcome to the power of omics my
name is jenny ho and i'm an email sales
support specialist for proteomics
a thermo fisher scientific and i will be
your moderator for today's event
today's webinar session is part of a
special event we are running this year
in advance of the international pupil
connect meeting outlining the power of
proteomics
in key application areas this event will
will discuss how scientists are
harnessing the power of proteomics
to advance scientific research over the
three days you will hear first from our
plenary speaker
in the opening session followed by
selected scientists in the second daily
session
it will provide an overview of the
current state of research in their
individual fields
the third session will feature a round
table discussion led by a prominent
researcher providing a look
towards the future and giving you the
opportunity to join in with what i hope
will be a very interactive and
interesting discussion
day one of the event focused on tackling
virus research
day two of the event focus on proteomics
and cancer
today is day three and the focus of
today's session is go beyond unleashing
the power of proteomics
in the last decade proteomics has become
a widely adopted technique
often multidisciplinary requiring
collaborations
with biologists protein chemists mass
spectrometrists and bioinformaticians
delivering new innovation
and diverse applications and workflows
to understand biology
modern proteomics solutions rely on
scientific community pushing the limits
of mass spectrometry technology
and going beyond mass spectrometry with
complementary developments
in sample preparation fifa purpose
reagents methodologies and more
this session highlights several of these
collaborations including single cell
proteomics
native ms for structural analysis
multiplex proteomics and artificial
intelligence
that enables mass analysis of proteins
from any organism
significantly faster than before and
almost error-free
continuing with the theme of community
collaboration we will also feature a
roundtable session
that will discuss future needs both
technology applications
and the need for standards that will
deliver the promise of proteomics for
human health
as we go through the program please use
the q a function to type in your
questions
and we will try to address as many of
these after each presentation
so without further any delay i'd like to
introduce our primary speaker professor
neil kalaher from northwestern
university
so over to you professor kalaher
great thanks for having me today and to
talk at this thermosponsored event
and to connect with you even from afar
and
uh through recorded means uh on
measuring protein level biology
one ion at a time so i'm happy to be
here and present
on a wide range of topics
and let's dive right in um
our summary here is i thought i'd warm
us up with what's on the minds of many
in a worldwide pandemic and that's
just a little bit of science around
sarsko v2
and kobit 19 and uh then move into
how some of the data i'll present uh was
created
and that's this really exciting
development of individual
inms i'll refer to it as i2ms for short
and we'll take a veritable romp through
a set of topics
including antibodies and getting some
world records
on resolving power set with this new
technology
and using it to deconvolve protein
complexity
and i'll show some native and top-down
mass spectrometry on vlps
and other topics of the day at the very
end i'll share with you some new
advances
and a new stream of separations and how
to
prepare samples for things like i2ms
in a really new way so let's dive right
in
and uh you know many of you
may know about uh all the vaccine
development being sponsored by
warp speed here in the united states and
uh novavax has received uh
the majority of funds here that are the
largest amount of the funds
from one sole company and that's about
two billion dollars in total
and that's uh uh been
pumped into novax which is a protein
based vaccine
a nanoparticle that that presents the
spike protein
of the virus uh in a in a way that
mimics
uh the actual surface of virions
and um it's been the focus of a lot of
uh
press and certainly 2 billion dollars so
it's 1.6 billion u.s
for from the federal government of the
united states and then
another about 400 million from a
not-for-profit
uh entity called sepi and
uh you know what it's taking is
is an approach to vaccine development
that's focused on this glycoprotein the
spike protein
of sars kobe 2. i'm not going to belabor
the introduction
of all the virology and other things
this this isn't a covet 19 talk
but i will say that both in europe and
the united states
of this podcast called
twith this week in virology
it's hosted by this fellow vincent
bracaniello and
embraces several guests from
european countries and it's just been a
tremendous
growth potential to learn about
immunology and virology
and so that's what i've been doing
during the pandemic
let's uh focus on this glycoprotein
the spike protein from stars kobe 2 and
let's look at its structure articulated
with all the glycans and that's what you
see in magenta here
on this slide is the glycans uh you know
several dozen n-linked glycosides
are on this protein and you know the
speed of this
uh research our response to the pandemic
as
uh scientists and biotechnologists
has been overwhelming and the the pace
of this
uh is just unprecedented so uh here's
just a small sliver of this
to to get us warmed up uh into our talk
there this afternoon
in europe and uh i just draw your
attention to this
uh structure of and a neutralizing
antibody
with the spike protein and i'm going to
just
focus in down on a
panel d here in the lower left and so
let's zoom in on that
and what it is it's it's actually
mediated by some of those glycans
so on the spike protein of sars kobe 2
uh there is an n linked glycan on on
asparagine 343
highlighted here and the neutralizing
antibody
has both light chain and heavy chain
recognizing the spike protein through
that glycan so that's just a little bit
of science to tea up just that the
protein diversity
in that world is critical to understand
and to a better measure
and so the the pandemic has just laid
this bare and i hope that you and yours
have
been safe and uh that you too have been
energized
to try and improve the world through
science
and so let's get into uh things you're
more used to
in this kind of forum and that's a mass
spectrum
of a the spike protein so this is the
receptor binding domain the part of the
spike protein
that is recognized by ace2
receptor on the surface of human cells
and so this receptor binding domain that
part of the spike protein
is also heavily glycosylated and here i
just show you a spectrum
of the glycoproteoform profile
in the 30 to 35 kilodalton range now the
underlying protein is is itself 26
kilodaltons just over and
you can immediately see that the the
shift in mass
is due to the glycans about five and a
half kilodaltons of glycans
and you see that that profile and so
it's
trivial now for us to get this mass
spectrum
and i'll tell you why that is and how
that is
uh in just a moment and so we can do
this in denaturing mode
or do this in native mode and here in
native mode
we see that this uh this construct forms
a dimer
and a trimer like the natural spike
protein itself
and we can get isotopic resolution on
all these different forms
uh even up to 100 kilo dalton at low
intensity
and get these glycoprotein profiles i
mean this is
now trivial to do and so to get this
spectrum
and this information uh before the
advent of i2ms
uh versus after is like night and day
and let me go on to tell you uh some
more about that
and so i2ms is a new technology
that leverages a a a non-incremental
improvement
in the past couple years that we've been
working on
and uh it's been announced there's six
publications with two more coming so
it's a veritable storm
of of papers on this
and let me highlight that for you and
let me also tell you the story
about how this came to be and
it basically uses an orbee trap
to assign the charge on each and every
uh ion that is uh passes through
the hardware measurement and software
processing
that we've set up and um this
has been a collaboration with the group
of mike senko
at thermo fisher scientific
in san jose california and uh and his
team
and mine we assembled ourselves in
october of 2017
and then proceeded down this uh very
fast train of development
and that's the story i wish to tell you
today and to acknowledge the the whole
team
uh that pulled this off and i really
believe this to be
as i said a non-incremental gain and so
why do i believe that
uh what is it about these are the things
i'll answer
and i'll actually move through the talk
fairly quickly
i appreciate that it's a virtual event
and
but let me let me try to engage you uh
as best i can
and then answer some q a uh in a few
minutes
so um charge detection mass spectrometry
is not new
and it has used single lines in the past
all the way back to the late 90s
uh with a fellow named henry benner more
recently
you know evan williams and martin gerald
in particular have advanced
an iron trap format where
they get very good charge assignment
accuracy
uh on one ion or maybe up to ten ions at
a time
uh uh but the positioning of that ion on
the mass spectrum is
is not great of course an orbee trap has
great frequency
accuracy but before this effort
it was not possible to assign the exact
charge
on an individual ion now it is
and we can then take advantage of
the fantastic frequency of
uh accuracy of the orbit trap and as
we've shown we can now move into the
thousands of ions per
shot uh into the orbit trap and do this
in a
you know it's kind of paradoxical but
it's
it's you could understand it as a
multiplexed
individual ion mass spectrometry
approach
so we can do what i'll show you on
thousands of ions at a time
in this paper reference at the bottom
left of this slide
we were doing it on 110 ions at a time
on average and basically you know you
bring
a population of 110 ions into an ion
trap
uh like the orbitrap and you
you you seek to use uh the intensity
to assign what is the charge so
in this case you're looking at on the
left hand side of the slide
the charges of myoglobin charge states
of ions of myoglobin and you're looking
at a histogram of intensities
for the different charge states and you
can see they're all over the place
and using intensity alone is fraught
with
challenges and problems and so uh we've
gotten around that and on the right-hand
side of the slide
what we use is the central limit theorem
to
converge on the correct answer and this
is in this paper is quoted at 96 percent
of the time
but we push that now also to approach 99
of the time
the the accuracy of the charge
assignment and let me let me
tell you how uh we've done that um
and um you know there's all sorts of
challenges in this business like ions
dying during detection
or two ion events that happen to overlap
etc so how do you make this a robust
process
and here's an example
of now connecting with some of the raw
data for
that underlies i2ms so these are four
ions
of the 20 plus charge state of myoglobe
and the goal of the exercise is to say
that each one is 20 plus
right this these are isotopic peaks
they're looking at so a and b
uh are isotopic peaks
uh for well-behaved ions and if why well
behave
what i mean to say is that over a two
second
detection period as they're spinning
through the orbit trap
you can integrate
the current that is induced by those
ions as they fly through
uh and fly around the center electrode
and so
as you integrate the the accrued current
over time
you can see that over a two second
period in the graph in the upper right
uh that you get more and more integrated
uh
signal and it's actually the slope of
this ion
that we have locked in on and said that
slope and we call this a story plot so
it's a story
slope and that's all published in the in
the paper
referenced in the lower left of this
slide um but that slope defines the
charge state
right so if that's a 20 plus ion then a
21 plus would have a slightly higher
slope and a 19 plus
a slightly lower slope now ions c and d
are uh fragmentation events and
so they aren't well behaved but we can
still recover them as 20 plus charges
and that's because we're using the slope
not the intensity
and that's how the core of the method
works
um again this is published now this was
the cover article
from nature methods in april
of this year and
it is diagrammed in this slide here
and let me now quickly take you through
again the process
and now we're going to multiplex it so
here comes 110 ions
on average shot into the orbit trap
and right there let me just stop and and
mention
that we actually have to detune the
uh instrument to make sure that just a
few ions are entering at any given time
so there's the one way to detune is only
inject ions for a very short burst
so sub millisecond bursts or you can use
very dilute solutions and um
i'll only make this point now but that
uh you know we've
instead of using uh low micromolar
concentrated samples we now use
concentrations
of low nanomolar and that too is a way
to make sure that
a hundred or a thousand ions per shot
are going in
okay with that digression let me
reconnect with the slide here
and uh note that we shot in about 110
ions
and you're looking at um the frequency
of those in the upper left
and then you go through the steps of the
process right which for every individual
ion we create this story plot as i
showed you and we we
anchor on the slope of that plot
to determine the charge on that ion
and we refer to a calibration i'll
mention the calibration to you
uh shortly and show you uh that it's
quite stable
over time over months periods of time
and then we can produce a true mass
spectrum
a a depiction of those ions in the mass
domain because we know the charge state
and the m over z or frequency we can
create a true mass spectrum and that's
the breakthrough
so uh the story slope here uh
we actually have to calibrate it
and so here you have both in denatured
mode
in red and in native mode in blue
and so we've used the q exactive plus or
now in hf
and the q exactive uhmr which we
co-developed with thermo
uh about half a decade ago and
we have uh got the slopes now
that we can now use as reference so
the story slope is now the y-axis
and the charge is on the z-axis and
using known calibrants we now get a
stories plot
we get a slope for an individual ion we
then refer to this
plot and then determine the charge
also co-adding many common ions at a
time
and this improves our charge assignment
accuracy
so uh this is stable over amazingly over
weeks and months
it doesn't require uh major hardware
changes
and just a bit of software to be able to
implement this
and this is being increasingly supported
by
thermo and beta tested etc so
it's it's in the pipeline um
moving forward uh this was
uh highlighted in a cna news article
so after calibration we can now use
uh use it and the approach
is benchmark here on a standard
monoclonal antibody and not even one
that's clean
and what you've got here is just a
reduced
monoclonal antibody into its light and
heavy chains
and uh in normal standard
ms you have uh
the left-hand slide here the data set
shows the rising baseline that is uh
standard in the field and this is
because of a lot of
glycosylations and a lot of
co occurrence of the ions
and you see that rise baseline that is
completely different when you go
to i squared ms and on the right hand
side you see this plot
where the light chain and the heavy
chain in the lower right here
have a very different appearance
and there are some guangding addicts at
plus 60 daltons
also making this a more complicated
spectrum
uh but it's readily read out and the
baseline
is is completely flat it's it's a very
different
sort of world than standard or ensemble
ms
when you go to i2ms
now we have used the technology for a
couple years now and
it's uh it's like any single molecule
approach and here we have
the positioning of the ions in frequency
is is also advantaged so when you have a
single ion spinning inside the
instrument
its frequency precision can be asserted
with much better
accuracy because you know it's a single
ion
so you can uh position it
accurately and then you acquire uh
many thousands of such events and you
can now
build up a isotopic distribution
easily at what you might call a super
resolution and so this is beyond the
instrument settings
uh that you would normally expect a
resolution of
x you get 20x gain and this was reported
back in 2019 on a monoclonal
we've since moved beyond that and with
i2ms we have
a world record now uh not once but twice
on this slide let me explain it to you
so using two tetrameric homo tetramer
complexes
pyruvate kinase and beta galactosidase
one on the left is pk pyruvate kinase
at about 232 kilodaltons
and the other one is over 466
kilodaltons on the right
um in both cases we can get isotopic
resolution on an orbeez
i mean that's that's just amazing and uh
and we do it by what i just said and
showed in that
prior article so when you resolve
things isotopically you can make sure
that you're not
shifting the mass by the underlying
species because you've resolved them
and so uh pyruvate kinase has um
some mild differences here including a
truncation
of one of the sub units one of the four
subunits here on the lower left
that's this uh peak at around two two
nine five hundred um
for biogalactosidase uh we have a major
shift in mass from that expected
um and and we go on in this paper to
describe
why that might be but there's no
question that's unit resolution
as shown in the inset on the lower right
so
that just shows one or more advantage of
i2ms and let's continue on
so here's another uh depiction of this
where
uh the experiment we did here which is
in the paper
uh in this article mentioned before
we took the entire uh wholesale extract
from hec293 cells
and isolated the 5 to 30 kilodalton
chunk of the proteome so the entire
mixture there we then
uh cleaned it up in the ways we normally
do prior to lcms
but didn't do lc we simply injected it
into the instrument
and did an ensemble measurement and you
can imagine
the result of this right which is it we
we
call this affectionately the hump of
death that
uh is way too many charge states
for way too many protein forms all
overlapping
so it's unintelligible you can't
determine masses
however if you do the exact same
experiment
and acquire data of i2ms data
on the right-hand side remember that
baseline i was describing
you can see the flatness of the baseline
and now we've detected a thousand
uh different masses for protein forms
and if we now refer to the lcms
experiment
and the set of of protein forms and
their
protein form records in a database the
intact mass values of them
we can begin to assign uh some of the
thousand masses and we did that for
about half of them here
uh using the intact mass as a basis to
assign a proteoform record number
uh in a proteform atlas that sits with
the consortium for top-down proteomics
on this website which is tdpro.org
so that just shows you night and day
right you've got left-hand
ensemble measurements you can't get any
mass values
out of it and on the right-hand side you
get
super resolution and clarity about the
mass spectrum on a very complex mixture
um so this is the basis for my statement
about i2ms that
uh you know we can approach any target
in biology it could be the spike protein
from covid
19 and soros cov2 uh heavily
glycosylated hundreds of kilodaltons
what whatever the complexity of it is
this is the technology
that will give you a mass distribution
uh very exciting and
and you know because many of you have
tried intact or top down
ms in various ways but it's the sample
prep
and there's this barrier to collecting
first can i see the protein forms that
are present in my sample
this and now we can do that and get a
mass distribution
irrespective of the molecular complexity
we're dealing with
and speaking of top down we've used the
technology as well this was the
cover article for jpr journal of
proteome research
from back in march and what i'm going to
show you is just a snippet of data here
on trios
phosphate isomerase tpi it's an enzyme
central and glycolysis
and we'll just focus on just the 39 plus
charge state
uh so we isolated that and then
fragmented it
and compared with ensemble and with i2ms
readouts
let's look at the data
so uh on the left hand side is the
traditional ensemble
readout and on the right hand side is um
msi2ms or i i call it that uh
tandem ms read out using individual ion
mass spectrometry
that's the long form uh and
uh here is uh the readout so if you look
if you look at the
nature of these readouts of the tandem
mass spectrum of the 39 plus
of this protein tpi it's about a 40
kilodollar protein
you just see the nature of the the data
type is completely different
on the left you have the standard set of
isotopic
envelopes each with a charge state that
needs to be determined
and a certain baseline appearance on the
right you have
a a readout with a flat baseline
and using the i2ms a platform
so what does it look like when you
deconvolute or assign masses to all of
these
here is the here are those data
and in one form we've used a graphical
fragment map to show you where
these fragment ions land and i think the
things to zoom in on
are best described when i come back to
this slide let me go ahead one slide
and show you just uh in red are the
ensemble
they're standard approach and in blue
are the i2ms
readouts of these fragments you can see
there's just a tremendous difference in
the
average mass of the fragments
that's shown on the left-hand side with
the box and whisker plot
you know we're averaging somewhere
around twenty thousand dollars
for the readout of these fragment ions
of a forty kilo dalton protein
versus something like three kilodons for
this standard approach
um on the right you've got a colored
depiction of the same thing
now if i go back look at what we're
looking at here
the standard ms is in the
red fragment ions and the uh
i2ms readout is uh in blue
and when you look at look at the
complementarity pairs that we're getting
so the red are the standard approach and
you get these small b
ions in the in the top part of this
graphical fragment map
but look at the blue ones there are
these massive y
ions whereas you saw these smaller b
ions
um it's true in the middle of the
protein and then also
on the c terminus it's the same thing
where you have small y
ions standard approach massive b ions
um you know your b 330
ion right or your y uh 315
right these are now trivial to read out
so i'm
very excited about the potential for
this in top down
uh one other area of application uh are
on vlps or virus
like particles and uh assessing their
composition
and their cargo and it's the same
type of message of different application
and one that takes on particular
significance
during the kobit 19 era and so
here is a vlp lp it's it's uh
made up it's a capsid from the ms2 virus
and it is sprayed and
analyzed in standard ensemble ms and
gave this data
that you see in the lower left it is
unintelligible you can't determine a
mass value
all the charge states are overlapping um
and it has heterogeneous
uh oligonucleotide cargo so
a few kb of rna and dna are inside this
capsid as it is expressed from e coli
so
on the right hand side you see the upper
part of the right hand
uh is the i2ms data and it's got a mass
of 3.19 megadalton
with a certain width to it and that
width is about 75 kilodaltons
and it's not due to the mass
spectrometry it's due to the biology
and i'll show you um the it's the length
variation of the oligonucleotide cargo
that underlies this so here's all these
charge states we're working at
between 131 and 140 plus charge states
and that's the answer of what was
underlying this hump in the lower left
um if you add up the cargo the dna and
rna cargo and we sequenced
the uh the cargo and we so we know it's
length distributions
the dna and the rna and you add it up
you get
uh very close to that expected um
and so we're we're reported this in the
paper
and i'll show you one more example
there's actually a mini-me
version of this the mini ms2
virus like particle it's a from a single
point mutation
of changing a single serine to a proline
at position 37.
this is a collaborative with uh
professor danielle
tilvanersick and
we there are cryo-em structures of these
vlp particles
and from that we know the number of
oligomers and the diameter
right so we've gone from 180 uh subunits
on the wild type capsid here down to
uh and 27 nanometers down to 60
subunits and 17 nanometers so it's going
to be a much lower mass
we're at 3.2 mega daltons uh on the far
left
what are we on the on the right and
that's shown here
along and i'll just let this slide pause
for a few seconds
these are the underlying sequences of
the dna and the rna
and you can look at the length
distributions and pause the
the talk if you like and work that out
it's also published
but it's the same basic uh deal where
there were even at this
lower uh mini-me version of this
vlp you couldn't assign the charge
states
with standard but with i2ms it's trivial
uh to determine the mass distribution
and it weighed in
at just under omega dalton a 0.99 mega
dalton
with a width about 32 kilodalton wide
and again that's due to the
heterogeneity of the oligonucleotide
cargo and the math there is on the
center part of the slide
we're down to 60 to 70 plus charge
states um
so we're looking into uh fragmenting
these and all sorts of fun with this uh
this new approach
so let me move on
in the interest of time and
come to the last part of my talk and
focus
on the sample handling problem the front
end problem
of mass spectrometry now we all know
that
this is a part of the secret sauce that
is really critical to get right
if your sample is not clean and ready
for mass spectrometry
you will get a sub optimal data
we now can get you a mass distribution
even under very dirty circumstances but
wouldn't it be great if we had
a protein concentration device
and a washing machine for automated
buffer exchange
that was applicable to uh up to a
a few tenths of percents of sds and some
of the
gnarliest kinds of buffer components
that we're used to working with
and we also need to have this work at
the mid to low nanogram
range this is what sample stream
represents
and what i'm going to finish off telling
you about um
so uh the device itself is is
uh embedded in this uh on the ctc
pal3 robot uh and so leverages all of
the availability of that
workflow and then it's hanging here this
black
three pumps the the actual sample stream
channel
is this teflon white piece and let me
zoom in on the next slide
of what happens inside the device uh
but but it's very efficient package that
we've been working on for
about five or six years and it goes live
here
uh in the first quarter of 2021
a year that uh hope will bring vaccine
great weather and more return
to normalcy for more people all around
the world
so for a sample stream itself it's
basically a protein concentration device
and washing at the same time and so what
it uses is counter flow
uh after sample injection uh the counter
flow
uh uses the chromato focusing effect
to line up those red balls that's your
analyte depicted here
and so that's the concentration effect
and then it also
has this molecular weight cutoff
membrane embedded
and because of that you have this
downward flow and we're talking
you know with with the pumps that you
saw a 100 microliter 200
400 microliters uh of of stringent
washing
and buffer exchange while you're
concentrating
so this is the the magic of sample
stream
is to be able to do that at the nanogram
level
now when you have your sample processed
uh
and ready to you've got to now get it
into either a fraction
so the pal 3 robot is capable of
fraction collection
now you've got a concentrated sample in
a different buffer with high recovery
or you can send it straight to the mass
spectrometer
and this is what we're of course working
on
feverishly here during the pandemic
and what we do is we switch a valve on
the pile 3 robot and
that diverts the flow into a
robust uh source at you know anywhere
between one and
fifty microliters a minute into
uh the norbi trap mass spectrometer and
uh it gives a profile evolution
just like a chromatography peak and
uh you know with all the advances in
mass spectrometry even if this is a
modest mixture
we will be able to uh do top-down native
top-down
or just get a mass distribution and so
here's a direct comparison of sample
stream to
lc and uh um the virtue of not having it
all the complications of lc are minifold
and uh having the repetition rate
of about at the fastest we've gone is 15
seconds per sample
but to allow for very complicated
samples
and buffer exchange this run was done of
a monoclonal antibody
in 2.5 minute per sample versus 6 minute
lc run times
and so it can go reasonably fast it's at
the nanogram level this is 500 nanograms
of receptive and it gives the same kind
of peak
and we've also switched between native
mode and denatured mode
which also has advantages so um i think
i'm going to
move to to exit and
leave time for q a i think that's really
important um so
i'm not going to belabor the nature
native mode
uh switch for antibodies but you can
also do
enzymatic digestion in the channel or
reduction
of of disulfides for antibodies
and or even bottom-up or pnga's
digestion
so we've been demonstrating these things
um these are the
the brains and workhorses uh that we've
been collaborating with
on sample stream that's phil compton and
jared drader
and of course you know i think in
summary you you've just seen the the
central role
of the orbee trap and the continued
massive innovation
uh that's coming you know year in and
year out uh
and making us able to do more with the
same or less number of ftes that work
for us
i think this is uh a template for the
future
and um you know you see if you agree
with this statement about
that first bullet point you know is this
a new paradigm
for mass spectrometry you know i i think
it is
and uh i think it it lives up to that
billing because
of the of the all the advantages i've
described um
uh maybe even makes jj thompson uh
smile from his grave where he uh
you know invented uh the thompsonometer
and that means you always had a mass to
charge that's what we measured right
but now we're producing an actual true
mass spectrum
and so it's a mass spectrometer it's not
a thompson almond
um so i think it is a sea change
and so i2ms uh you know very quickly
generates data
and now with the world record at 466
kilodaltons for isotopic resolution
um and you know using uh it's a profile
of glycoproteoforms
on the the spike protein of sars kobe 2
or or any complicated uh molecular
weight distribution and we
all know that that's happening in
pharmaceuticals biopharma
and advanced therapeutics
vlps uh and aavs they're just
um prevalent uh and and so this
technology
and with an approach to solve the
front-end problem
and really uh make what used to take
phds
able to be done um with uh
more junior staff and that lower price
point
per measurement um and so economies of
scale will be coming
and um with that i think i'll just thank
danielle who has been a spectacular
collaborator on the vlps
and the virus-like particles with bon
iqbagu and the whole team really both at
thermo and my team without which
none of this would be possible i want to
thank
mike and vlad and all the thermo group
um and then particularly jared kuffader
phil compton jack mcgee rafael milani
ken durbin
brian earley ryan fellers and louise
shachner
i also want to acknowledge the national
institutes of health
and funding our proteomics center and
the keck foundation
and the sherman fairchild foundation for
its support
thank you for your attention and i'm
happy to answer any questions thank you
a stimulating uh presentation i think we
have a few questions in the
chat box let me just open up okay
so one of the questions is for the
individual iron approach how broadly
applicable is it in terms of molecular
complexity of the analytes in other
words how complex is too complex
right uh thanks jenny and uh can you
hear me okay
yes i can yes okay perfect thank you um
and thanks for the forum and i hope
you're doing well
uh yeah i made some claims there in the
video and i
i stand right by them i mean the
complexity of the sample can be extreme
and uh we haven't yet found a sample
where we can't generate a mass
distribution
um provided that you're in you know the
the
low to mid nanomolar regime
and as i said you know these
concentrations
uh can be still quite low relative to
normal
uh micro molar type samples and the
complexity
you know you can have of thousands even
tens of thousands of different
molecular species in a sample and still
get the mass distribution
and that was demonstrated directly in
the talk so
i appreciate the question and for those
mass spec
experts in there let me just quickly
explain why in 30 seconds
um in the ensemble approach in a fourier
transform mass spectrometer
the basis of signal is the constructive
interference
of the ions uh many thousands of ions
uh they have to compound on each other
to give you this readout in the time
domain
um in the new method uh it's
no longer the basis of signal you do not
need constructive interference
it's individual ion each ion gives its
own
readout and that's that's a little quick
summary about about why that is
so it doesn't matter that you don't have
enough ions
uh of the same protein from the exact
same
isotope of law guinea so
that that long-winded answer but there
you go jen
thank you so has your team performed any
quantitative analysis did you find
like the lod or the lower limit of
quantitation
for this methodology ah oh the linear
working curve and its characterization
yeah just enough to know that you know
where things
drop off in the you know sub nanomolar
regime
you know we we haven't done an exact
characterization of the lower limit of
quantitation
that will require a bit more work or or
other people can contribute to that
with different analytes would be
different answers
depending on their complexity and
but uh you know in the lod we you know
uh
yeah i think i'm comfortable with saying
hi picomolar range but we need to lock
that down on on specific analytes
okay okay so in one of the the slides
um you showed a calibration curve the
story calibration curve he had one for
denatured and one for native
why is that oh right yeah i guess
uh it's a great question i i think i
convoluted two issues on that slide
um there were two instruments on that
slide so one was a q exactive plus
and one was a uhmr um and
uh that that's why so each instrument
needs a calibration um and
yeah so you i would i would still want
to cover the
uh range of charge states over which you
want to calibrate and that
in native can be quite different quite
much higher
in charge but in principle you should
need just one curve for one instrument
okay okay
another question is is i2ams compatible
with chromatography
and any potential benefits
uh yeah that's uh so whoever asked that
is um
intimating the future and got a lovely
development vector for us mapped out
there so great
great question yeah right now i would
say that's really tough
um and this is partly why the connection
with sample stream
it makes so much sense sample stream
allows you to
elute in a chromatographic like peak but
over a time frame that's you know at
least a minute wide or
two minutes you can you can change it
you could have it be five minutes wide
and so if you have an especially
complicated sample
of you know chromatography with
with the detection on say a tribute
system
or the eclipse uh you know it goes fast
enough that you can do it
um for i2ms that's still a challenge i
would say
uh so you would need you know a minute
or two
at the very least to to generate some of
these data
now we're working on uh on that exact
topic so uh
standby okay there's been a few
questions regarding
um is ims too feasible on all
orbitrap mast analyzers or instruments
yeah so technically feasible um you know
probably or
sort of you know where there's a lot of
complexities to it and and individual
ions
are uh you know very sensitive to things
like the vacuum
and and why do individual ions die you
know i
uh there's many reasons um but you know
we
most of the instruments we've looked at
are uh orbee traps that give
seventy eighty ninety percent ion uh
uh lifetime stability the the ions don't
die
up to 80 you know you need sort of 70 80
of the of the ions not to die during
this
uh one or two second detection period
and not all instruments uniformly do
that so i but i but i think supported
instruments like the uhmr
moving forward into next year uh that'll
for sure be true
and so um you know i think that
the rest is up to thermo and mike senko
vlads of ruskoff and all of their peers
and co-workers to decide about that and
but in principle yeah i mean it's just
but some instruments could give
low percentage uh iron uh survival rates
uh so that's something to look for
okay thank you so we have a question
about
um do you think i2ms will be a great
competi real competitor for standard
top-down approaches for complex samples
comparative to multi-dimensional
separations
in the new feature ah so i think the
question is in the context of
proteome top down proteomics and
discovery mode and
trying to maximize the coverage you know
i
i
hope so um i think it will take uh you
know
a few short years to to make that a
reality
and it's of course a question of how
many resources we can
funnel into the development for now i
would think
about it mostly as a targeted method for
targeted targeted proteoform discovery
uh put it that way where you've got an
analyte it might have
thousands or tens of thousands of
protein forms which is
really complicated but the tandem mms
allows you to map ptms we've used it to
do
proteomics where we don't know the
identity of the target
but for broad large high throughput
studies
doing proteomics that that's not its
wheelhouse right at the moment
okay okay so going back to the top-down
proteomics in one of the slides you
showed um
the uh sequence coverage of a protein
using the traditional method
and the tandem im2 ms method
and you also mentioned that we see
observe larger fragments
can you explain why that is given that
um
i guess the fragmentation is the same um
yeah it was exactly the same ions
exactly the same
everything was the same it's just the
readout differed
um and so it was an apples to apples
comparison there in the data you saw for
the
the tpi the trios phosphate isomerase
and uh yeah the the the bias difference
between the the for the mass detection
of the two
are very different you know the ensemble
standard method
advantages you to detect low mass b and
y ions
and for years i thought well okay so why
are we not seeing
the b300i right i mean when's the last
time you saw the b300 right
at a coffee shop last week no that was
elvis presley no
that it was just they just are of many
charge states many isotope peaks
they are there but sort of in this
rolling baseline
now switch to i2ms and you get
the very completely changed mass bias
you actually get
better as you get higher in mass so
there's the b300
you can have coffee with him or her you
can just you know there it is
and all of his friends like it just the
readout is
totally differently biased i'm very
excited about this because the sequence
coverage
goes way up and the certainty with which
you can localize ptms
goes way up um so i think when you think
about other fragmentation methods on say
the tribrid and you know i just think it
it's it's a non-incremental game sorry
jenny i get excited
i'm talking about elvis presley right
yeah
okay so um
that's another question
okay what is the largest um protein or
protein complex that you've analyzed
with this methodology
yeah oh 20 mega in excess of 20 mega
dollars and
um uh so like the the size limit
is um you know limited more about how
you get the ions
into the instrument and so the uhmr is
is tuned to uh ions of even higher mass
so
you know i look forward to going to the
30 to 100 mega dalton range
um and the mass distributions can be
generated so long as the ions make it
uh to the to the trap to the orbit trap
and so um i think that's the limitation
okay um kind of a two-part question
um this itms technology how do you
establish a spray over many hours
like 72 hours and how long does the
computing time take
to acquire this data and to to
deconfluent
yeah so that that's a that's a great
question in the paper
the longest we've gone is four days
and that was to generate that one result
on the 1000 protiform
sample but you know that's that was then
and this is now uh and and then i mean
you know things are being dealt with
like hey we were dealing with raw
transients at the time
right all these you know very expensive
in terms of compute
storage and and processing times
expensive now we don't have to deal with
transients and we're dealing with just
much reduced versions of the data sets
so you know it's already sped up 10 fold
it'll speed up another 10 fold
the processing time for both the file
size which is already shrunk by 100
and the processing times also will
approach 100 fold
reduction and there were they were
extensive they were uh
yeah it would take many hours to process
such a data set
but now we're now we're down to an hour
and
for even a very long you know direct
infusion experiment
uh and to answer the second part of that
question it was you know just simple
syringe
pumping for days into the instrument
reload a syringe
but you know this is why the sample
stream you know you can't do that
with a nanogram of protein right
so the sample stream piece of this is to
be able to take
tens of nanograms change their buffer
control access to the sample with high
efficiency introduce it for say five ten
thirty minutes of 70 minutes um
and and that's what we've uh we've got
going
uh with the sample the combination of
the two
okay and then i think we have enough
time for one more question
is um is the itms technology including
the software already available on
um orbitrat platforms including
uh for example the customer has a qx
active biopharma
instrument uh yeah that's that would be
a great
instrument uh to focus on
and uh you know so uh i would refer to
vlad zabruzkoff and and mike senko on
this one are deferred to them
but yeah it technically yes it's through
a beta test program
and so you know go chase those two folks
down or
or the folks that thermo can can connect
you up with the right
folks and emails um and and get into
that program
i think it'll be you know a few months
more before
they can expand access but certainly by
you know next year and the timelines
up to up to thermo fish or scientific
but yeah
so it'll it'll it'll be available uh
shortly in a more widely
accessible format and the uhmr
is is the main focus point uh so the
biopharma
is um you know i guess the the technical
point let me just address the technical
question
and that is that the uh in for native
ions
uh the center electrode voltage is
is not a problem um where
you know you could have a kv center
electrode or a 1kb
and and things basically function well
good ion survival rates
for denatured mode uh when you
especially when you get higher in mass
you know you need to reduce the voltage
on the center electrode
and so that's just one type of
technical um consideration you know when
you
the types of ions differ in their
survival rates depending on the
center electrode of the orbit trap so at
the center of electrode voltage
so uh yeah i hope that that answered
basically the question
jenny and um you know i just want to
thank julian saba and
uh claudia and you know all the
collaboration
partners at thermo fisher scientific and
for all the listeners thanks for chiming
in there
and um we look forward to 2021.
thank you professor kaher that's a very
good presentation
and thank you to the audience for
listening and participating
so we will um reconvene in 30 minutes
for
session two um so with that i just like
to close the session
this session anyway and i'll speak to
you and see you
in half an hour thank you bye-bye